c'est beau comme vous avez l'air
amoureux moi ça fait 42 ans que je suis
fou amoureux de la même tu vois que ça
existe c'est quoi votre secret
41 ans qu'on s'est pas vu
il faut que tu t'arranges pas les
retrouver ou alors faut que tu la
retrouves de nuit pour pas qu'elle soit
déçu de quoi tu as vu ta gueule on
dirait un chapelle quoi
c'est moi ça
bon tu descends et tu vas retrouver ta
violette ok mais il fait jour et alors
tu m'as dit de la retrouver de nuit bon
ça va tous les coups vu son âge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est qui
était au Club Med de ma naissance à
maintenant je m'appelle trident trident
du Club Med
tu pourrais quand même accueillir à ton
petit frère demi-frère encore mieux je
prends moins de place je veux retrouver
mon amour d'enfance de mes 8 ans
violette je peux dormir ici alors oui je
savais je le savais ça
non plus tu as vu ta gueule
[Musique]
une erreur que sa ville est là-bas au
Club Med déjà tu t'appelles plus Roxane
tu t'appelles violette ok je m'appelle
violette voilà
non tu t'appelles violette oui ok
je te jure
toi tu t'appelles toujours lui
évidemment
j'ai l'impression d'être dans un film
d'espionnage j'adore sexy
heureuse
de ma
vie non trident pas
[Musique]
parce que j'ai retrouvé
ça fait si longtemps
oui pardon c'est l'émotion de le revoir
[Musique]